foreign
for everybody's favorite facts are your
friends let's do it
managers impact employee mental health
more than therapists or their spouse
that's the title of this new article
here
whoa that's all I'm saying whoa
if this is true this is this is
shapeshifter for most of us because the
the all of the data suggests that the
most important decision a person makes
is who they marry
um a great partnership with your spouse
ends up in a much larger net worth it
ends up in longer life it ends up in
Better Health better happiness all these
metrics go this way and a bad spouse
somebody who um you're always at war
with
um leads to negative metrics and so I've
always told young people always the most
important decision is not where you go
to college not what you major in it's
who you decide to spend the rest of your
life with
and so when an article comes out it says
managers impact employees mental health
more than their spouse or partner or
more than their therapist
we gotta stop that bus and back that
thing up all right so here's what it
says the workforce Institute at ukg
surveyed 35 3 400 people across 10
countries to find out the role managers
play in influencing their staffer State
of Mind
in fact
managers impact workers mental health
more than both doctors and therapists
according to the study now really quick
I'm going to give you an a 0.02 second
lesson on reading articles
this in big bold letters here's what the
title of this article is managers impact
employees mental health more than
therapists and as much as a spouse or
partner
if you read it really quick it jumbles
it all together so it says it's about as
much as a spouse or partner okay now
going so make sure that the the title
matches what you're actually reading
down here those are often disconnected
because they want you to click on the
title and then you read it and it's like
ah well maybe not but that's not here
it's not surprising that 60 of those
surveys said that their job is the
biggest Factor influencing their mental
health now I want to push back on that
for a second
here's in in real quick we've created a
planet a universe a state of being
where all of us owe people money
we're all in debt
whether it's student loans whether it's
car loans whether it's housing whether
it's our rent whatever we all owe people
money and we're the loneliest generation
in human history we have nobody we got
nobody we have old high school friends
and we have long text threads full of
memes with that's it we have a couple of
college buddies who are in your sorority
or fraternity or whatever group you paid
to be friends with or on Old sports
teams or whatever
maybe you got a couple people from your
high school youth group
we're lonely
and we've pulled the string we've pulled
the tether on
um stories that unite cultures otherwise
known as religions
we're all like eh we're too smart for
that stuff now that's not real
and what we have are exhausted lonely
untethered people who have one common
place left the workplace
and so now the workplace is having to
teach us about issues of diversity about
sex ed because we didn't get that at
home we didn't get that at school
they're having to teach us uh they have
to provide us Health Care
they have to provide us a purpose they
have to provide us paycheck you see how
the workplace now is the Baseline for
all human Humanity it's the last great
line of defense
and so when people say my job is the
source of my mental health issue I don't
think so I think it's we've created a
world where the only connecting feature
left is work it's the only thing we got
left that defines us as a as a community
as a group of people it's the only place
I see humans anymore
and if you work remotely can't help you
man
all you see is Toddlers and your spouse
and jeez
so
I'll just move on a whopping 64 of
respondents said that work negatively
impacts their well-being
it's wild
work should be the thing that gives you
purpose and meaning and feels so right
and then you go home
and then you go connect with your
friends and then you go connect with
your faith community or you go do your
acts of service Etc
coincidentally
um there's a direct correlation between
feeling unable to balance work and home
priorities with poor mental health so
now you see what what's happening here
we've created unstable wildly out of
balance lives and we blame work for it
over 80 percent of employees worldwide
and seventy percent of workers in the
U.S would take a pay cut for a job that
so better supports their mental Wellness
what I want people to do is to actually
sit down and write down on a piece of
paper what is mental Wellness for me
what would that actually mean
time with friends fun
if it's video game time and doing
nothing time and laying around time I'm
going to tell you that's not mental
health that's numbing Behavior
opposite of mental health if it's time
to go on adventures and time to go
hiking and time to go hunting and time
to do painting or whatever play music
that now we're getting into building a
life worth living
the overwhelming majority of HR is a
continuing the article and c-suite
leaders think their employ their
workplace has a positive impact on work
or mental health
but half of the employees agree and I'll
tell you this I've seen this almost
every single place I've ever worked ever
ever consulted
and we've seen this in the data over the
last 25 to 50 years the disconnect
between
mid managers and lower entry-level
workers up through middle management and
that could be a six-figure job as a
middle manager and the execs
those that can afford all of the yoga
classes and the special stuff and the
and the massages and they're not they're
not worried about I can't afford eggs
right there's a gap between here's the
world we're creating I once was at a
place where the boss was like we don't
have politics here where we we're at
this at this workplace and I laughed and
said oh yeah you do yeah you do and
they're like no we don't we don't do
politics here it's like oh for sure you
do for sure we don't have a dress code
here you for sure have a dress code here
right so there's a disconnect between
the world that senior execs think
they've created and the world being
experienced by others and the easy thing
exacts I'm talking to you is to say
um I don't care they got to get in line
cool and what they're telling you is
they're falling apart
so I'm talking to both the employees and
the leaders here
the article goes on to say how managers
can influence their workers mental
health for the better and I actually
agree with all of the points here I
think they're great
first one is leaders need to avoid
burying their heads in the sand and
instead make mental health a global
topic of discussion within their teams
yes start having conversations
let people know that if they're not okay
or not well here's where resources are
here's what my expectations are for how
you need to take care of yourself here's
where you can go
and leaders make no mistake having a
somebody who's struggling with
depression struggling with anxiety show
up every day is going to decrease
performance individually and with your
whole team
you're much better off taking care of
people now they also have to get their
work done that's real you may have to
split people's jobs up to why people are
getting healthier getting whole all that
stuff's true but you got to stop bearing
your heads about you can start talking
about it
um this can be uh let's see here it
could be um
increase awareness or access to
available resources there can be uh
surveys that are Anonymous just to get a
pulse on what's going on in the in the
company and those are super helpful
sometimes people use those to lob
grenades they do they do but if you get
enough grenades at some point you
realize you're under attack and you
didn't know it
um also suggest that managers should be
open about their own personal struggles
with mental health and relationships to
destigmatize the topic
when any leader across the country asks
me how can I best support my staff
my team because they're struggling with
anxiety they're struggling with
depression they're struggling all these
things the first thing I always tell the
leaders is you call a meeting and let
them know that you're going to a
counselor
that you are taking a little bit of time
to go get well that you and your spouse
are going to see a marriage counselor go
do that lead by example you go first and
the whole organization will collectively
exhale and yes your shareholders can use
that against you they can they can
weaponize it your bosses your the board
members of whatever organization can be
like oh so-and-so struggling but yes
they can do that
and now you know how your employees feel
now you know
um one last thing here
um
managers should be encouraging workers
to take more time off work
use your vacation
this happens in two ways managers turn
your phones off one of the things I love
about working at Ramsey Solutions is you
know
Dave Ramsey will just pile send emails
off but they don't come until 6 a.m
they've all the execs here have fixed
their email accounts so when they send
emails after a certain time it doesn't
end up in our email boxes until the
morning
because they found out they were sending
an email just off the top of their head
like hey I want to see some numbers on
this thing at 10 o'clock and then
suddenly an employee was reading it at
10 and they were up till 4am trying to
find these numbers and unable to sleep
and stressing and that was not intention
of the email at all not even close
and so there's little things like that
and then there's bigger things like an
incentive if you use all your vacation
I'll give you two more days because the
data says people who use their vacation
make your company more money
they make your company more money and I
used to be really guilty leaders when I
had a whole bunch of direct reports I
would tell them you need to take some
time off you need to take some time off
but they had these big projects and so I
was actually stressing them out more
because now he's giving him time off was
that was becoming a job requirement a
responsibility
so I might have to find people to help
with those projects and say hey you got
to get out of here you got to delegate
this project to two other people I know
they can get it done or we have to
create a world where we can delegate
each other's projects because you got to
get it you gotta take a break
all this to say
when it comes to work and mental health
we've created worlds
very unhealthy worlds that our bodies
can't exist in and we're blaming work
for that and I think that's ridiculous
and leaders we have to understand that
we've there's such a gap between us and
entry-level employees we have to
remember what that was like and we think
we remember but we're wrong
we have to get into busy messy lives of
the people who are taking these
entry-level jobs these mid-management
jobs that are working their butts off
that have dreams and oh six figures in
student loan debt and they're trying to
make it all work and we have to remember
what that was like and we all think I
remember what those like we don't the
pressures are different now they're just
different
they're not better or worse they're just
different and we gotta listen we gotta
listen
leaders we gotta go first
that's why I'm always on this show
telling people I see a counselor I see a
marriage counselor I got a coach
I'm not perfect either and I do this for
a living
managers leaders we gotta go first
mental health at work by the way if your
job is causing your mental health to
collapse
you are worth something better than that
create a life worth living and find
other work I can't find the job there is
no better time in human history than to
find a new job than right now
go do it